donald trump has made a lot of
investments over his career
one of the flashiest his purchase of
mar-a-lago also turned out to be one of
the best trump paid an estimated 10
million dollars for it in 1985 and
turned it into a money-making club
before a rising real estate market made
it one of the most valuable homes in the
world today the crown jewel of palm
beach is worth an estimated 350 million
dollars the property which was rated by
the fbi monday was historic long before
trump got involved with it
finished in 1927 mar-a-lago was given to
the federal government by the will of
the original owner serial heiress
marjorie merriweather post in hopes it
would be used as a presidential retreat
the government ultimately decided to
give mar-a-lago back to the marjorie
meriwether post foundation concerned
about maintenance and security in 1985
the foundation sold it to trump who paid
a reported 5 million dollars for the
house 3 million for the furniture and 2
million for the beachfront land across
the road
this was around the time trump started
to get ahead of himself and several of
his business deals in the 80s including
his 1988 purchase of new york city's
plaza hotel ended in bankruptcy by the
early 90s but luckily for trump he was
able to hang on to mar-a-lago
in 1995 he turned the mansion into a
private club hosting rich members and
glitzy events in 2015 trump declared he
was running for president and though his
comments on the campaign trail turned
off some customers others flocked to the
palm beach residence in 2014 mar-a-lago
generated an estimated 10 million
dollars a year in revenue the year trump
announced his presidential run sales
jumped to an estimated 22 million
dollars they climbed to an estimated 29
million dollars the following year after
winning the election trump reportedly
doubled the initiation fee to two
hundred thousand dollars as president he
took so many trips to the club that his
administration began referring to it as
the winter white house in some ways it
was the fulfillment of marjorie
merriweather post's dream but in 2017
trump's first year in the white house
revenues hit 25 million dollars they
trickled down to 23 million dollars in
2018 and 21 million dollars in 2019. by
the time covet 19 hit in 2020 forbes
estimated mar-a-lago was worth 170
million dollars
in typical fashion the trump
organization argued its value was closer
to 500 million then something remarkable
happened while many of trump's
businesses flailed about in the early
days of the pandemic mar-a-lago held on
with revenues landing at an estimated 23
million dollars in 2020.
at that point the real estate market
took off thanks to a flood of wealthy
northeasterners who rushed to palm beach
like never before
that 500 million dollar figure absurd at
the time that the trump organization
proposed it suddenly became somewhat
reasonable
real estate experts outside of palm
beach guessed that the place was worth
more than 200 million dollars
brokers on the island thought it'd be
worth far more with the most aggressive
estimate coming in at
725 million dollars
when forbes last valued the property in
march we went with a conservative 350
million dollars if trump sold mar-a-lago
for that amount he'd reap a 35 times
return on his original 10 million dollar
investment making it one of the best
deals of his career
[Music]